[Music]
but the other side of its becoming
history is a conscious self-mediating
process Spirit emptied out into time but
this externalization this canosis is
equally an externalization of itself the
negative is the negative of itself this
becoming presents a slow-moving
succession of spirits a gallery of
images Each of which endowed with all
the riches of spirit moves thus slowly
just because the self has to penetrate
and digest this entire wealth of its
substance
as its fulfillment consists in perfectly
knowing what it is in knowing its
substance this knowing is its withdrawal
into itself in which it abandons its
outer existence and gives its
existential shape over to recollection
thus absorbed into itself it is sunk in
the night of its self-consciousness but
in that night it's vanished outer
existence is preserved and this
transformed existence the former one but
now reborn of the spirit's knowledge
is the new existence a new world and a
new shape of spirit
in the immediacy of this new existence
the spirit has to start afresh to bring
itself to maturity as if for it all that
proceeded were lost and it had learned
nothing from the experience of the
earlier spirits
but recollection the inwardizing of that
experience has preserved it and is the
inner being and in fact the higher form
of the substance so although this Spirit
starts afresh and apparently from its
own resources to bring itself to
maturity
it is nonetheless on a higher level that
it starts
the realm of spirits which is formed in
this way in the outer World constitutes
a succession in time in which one Spirit
relieved another of its charge and each
took over the Empire of the world from
its predecessor their goal is the
revelation of the depths of spirit and
this is the absolute notion
this Revelation is therefore the raising
up of its depth or its extension the
negativity of this withdrawn eye a
negativity which in is its
externalization or its substance and
this Revelation is also the notion's
time in that this externalization is in
its own self-externalized and just as it
is in its extension so it is equally in
its depth in the self
the goal absolute knowing or spirit that
knows itself is Spirit has for its path
the recollection of the spirits as they
are in themselves and as they accomplish
the organization of their Realm
their preservation regarded from the
side of their free existence appearing
in the form of contingency is history
but regarded from the side of their
philosophically comprehended
organization it is the science of
knowing in the sphere of appearance the
two together comprehended history form
alike the inwardizing and the
Calvary of absolute Spirit the actuality
truth and certainty of his throne
without which he would be lifeless and
alone
only
from The Chalice of this realm of
spirits Foams forth for him his own
infinitude
with paragraph 808 and the final
sentences in it this beautiful set of
lines from The Chalice of this realm of
spirits Foams forth for him his own
infinitude we finish hegel's
phenomenology of spirits and we're ready
supposedly to move on to other things
although this is the kind of work I
think many of you know this that rewards
re-readings so where should you go after
this maybe start at the beginning again
I don't know how many times I've read
this book through myself and perhaps
that would be a good idea for anybody
who is following along because things
will get richer to you as a term that
comes up in a number of places in this
paragraph So This is the culmination we
are getting to the point of comprehend
did history but graphene
and we are finally knowing ideally what
exactly absolute knowing is
and here Hagel is going to use a really
important term Miller translates it as
recollection I think that's a great way
to do it in a home right and it's going
to show up at different places in this
paragraph and it is recollection
not just of spirit
this is Spirit knowing itself but of
spirits
plural and we've talked about this in
the previous paragraphs there are shapes
gestalts right a Gestalt in plural of
Consciousness and in the last several
paragraphs Hagel has talked about these
in terms of shapes of spirit itself
and that is what we have been traversing
throughout this an absolute knowing
itself is also a final Gestalt a final
shape
a condition
of spirit of Geist mind whatever you
want to call it now I do have to point
out that Miller takes a few Liberties in
Translation that we'll point out in here
you know I try not to beat up on him too
much because as a translator I know how
difficult it is to render things well
from one language to another and I do
know the temptation of wanting to you
know Steer your translation in a certain
direction but I also want you to be
aware of what Hagel himself is saying
and and what Miller is saying that
hegel's saying so let's start at the
very beginning
we've talked about becoming viadin right
and a couple different
sides to it a couple different aspects
to it and then he says here's the the
next side to it the other side of it's
becoming verden
history
is a conscious knowing right and knowing
self-mediating uh so this is important
we were talking about the immediate
before now we were realizing how
mediated everything is and it's not just
mediated in terms of factors that we had
to dig up through you know studying
things and thinking about them it's
self-mediating and Hagel is going to you
know resort to some what we could call
at this point almost tropes
but we're not supposed to just view them
as tropes about how it is self-mediating
so he calls this a self-mediating
process now process is actually there in
again so becoming process those are the
same terms
that's the first thing that I want to
point out to you about Miller's
translation this becoming history is a
becoming Spirit now here we get to the
next thing emptied out into time but
this externalization so
gets used a lot in this paragraph and
Miller is going to instead of using one
term like externalization
he's going to translate it in a variety
of ways that might give you the idea
that we're using different terminology
here so Spirit emptied and or certainly
you know externalized into time this
externalization this canosis there's no
kenosis in the actual uh text is equally
an externalization
of itself
well of course it's an externalization
of itself it is doing the externalizing
and what is it externalizing what is it
you know putting outside of itself
itself as we saw again in previous
paragraphs so thus far other than you
know bringing history in very implicitly
he's not saying something radically
different and then he tells us it's the
the negative is the negative of itself
let's dwell on that for a moment
one thing that people when they're first
explaining Hegel to an audience that
perhaps doesn't know that much about it
they will bring up the role of negation
in Hegel and they will talk about
determinant negation right where you
have a first negation and then a
negation of the negation and you don't
simply it's not like uh minus and minus
turn into Plus
it's rather that minus minus turns into
something that's plus something that's
positive but it's not the same one that
you started with Things become
more complicated but more mediated more
explicitly connected related to each
other in the process of negating them
right so this should be familiar to all
of us by by this point I hope but it's
it's worth mentioning so then he goes
back to talking about this becoming this
becoming
presents a slow-moving succession
of spirits a a ordering in time we could
say as we're going to look at in a
moment and then he's got this
interesting metaphor
which is itself quite visual right a
gallery of images of
you know Builder
um is this a reversion back to
representation or picture thinking no
it's it's it's not but we look at
what has been going on through the
history that we've been
working our way through in the
phenomenology and that's a history of
shapes of Consciousness but you can also
call it a history of
Spirits plural
and here he reminds us of some very
important points
so he tells us
each of these images
endowed with all the riches
are both going to be used in this quite
a lot and there's of course a very close
continuity between them so when we see
uh for example the realm the Reich that
is where the right the wealth
can be found can occur can develop can
be mined we might even say so Each of
which endowed with all the riches of
spirit so each of the stages that we
went through previously in the
phenomenology was at least from the
Vantage points of that stage for a
little while before it was its
inadequacy and its need to be surpassed
was was understood its negation was
understood
each of them was endowed with all the
riches of spirit up to that point people
lived
not an impoverished life but a rich life
at that stage and experienced the
fullness of that stage they just didn't
realize that there was more than that or
maybe they did and it was presented to
them in a negation maybe we need to go
further with this and that's what the
dialectical process has been this entire
time now why can't we just like you know
run our way through it people is a bit
of a side note
sometimes people are like
I'm gonna speed run through Hegel right
that's a terrible idea you're not going
to understand anything if you do that
it's hard enough just going through at a
normal thoughtful attentive pace and
getting everything that hegel's saying
the first time that you read it through
or the tenth time that you read it
through you should not be trying to
watch these these things at 1.25 or 2.0
speed that's a stupid move I mean you
can say that about most philosophy that
you really need to linger her over it as
a matter of fact even when it comes to
literature or history you don't want to
be trying to cut corners
you don't want to try to speed up the
process
you gotta linger through it now Hagel
tells you why
why is that he says that the self has to
penetrate and digest this entire wealth
again
of its substance
so you know this is a good thing to
remember and then he goes on and he
talks about fulfillment right and um
these terms like fulfillment and
Perfection they're all Composites using
the
um
prefix full right to bring something to
its fullness uh to bring something to
its fully developed state to its end so
Perfection doesn't mean
Immaculate in the sense of like having
no flaws or anything like that or being
frozen in glass forever it means being
brought to a stage where there's nothing
left to add to it but you've got this
Dynamic living
complex living both in itself and in US
and so he goes on and he says
as its fulfillment consists in perfectly
knowing what it is in knowing its
substance this knowing is its withdrawal
into itself it's in the gayen we've seen
this term used a lot in the religion
section and the absolute knowing section
withdrawal into itself in which it
abandons now Hegel doesn't use the term
outer existence he just says daza so it
abandons its uh outer existence is what
Miller is saying it just abandons its
existence and gives its existential
shape over to recollection to Erin right
now what is its existential shape it's
spirit
so it's you know Gestalt uh what it is
that that existence the being being
there being in the world does it right
what is its form what is its structure
what is its type of consciousness
so he goes on and now here he brings up
self-consciousness thus absorbed into
itself it is sunk
in the night of its self-consciousness
but in that night it's vanished outer
existence again hegel's not using the
word outer there he's just saying dazine
but this is
um
that is disappearing a design that is
Vanishing right
um and that is being
turned into or replaced by something
it's vanished outer existence gets
preserved and this transformed
existence
is the new existence right
um the transformed existence is actually
an existence that is being
afgholdness
it's preserving stuff off Haven another
key hegelian term
in means to
not just surpass and leave behind but to
bring with you and integrate what was
essential what was most fully developed
from the previous position this is how
negation takes place in hegelian
dialectic right
so what is going on here
um
transformed existence the former one the
existence that it was before
but now reborn of the spirit's knowledge
and here now notice these
terms that he's using and notice too
that Hegel
does bring these together in threes at
several points in this final paragraph
and it's not the three of you know
thesis antithesis synthesis that silly
BS that isn't really Hegel uh that that
you see in the internet and bad history
of philosophy people summarizing Hegel
it's rather a Triad of
what we're talking about what the thing
is
the new existence
right
so
um
a new design
a new world new noise belt and a new
shape
of spirit
right shape of spirit shape of
Consciousness
um now it's why is it a shape of spirit
because spirit is what we've been doing
this entire time
we have been spirit all along
so a new shape of spirit that is also at
the same time a world
so it's not just the self
it's all the things the self is
surrounded by and engages with and it is
existence in that world it is design in
that new world
now it's not new as in again everything
we leave everything else behind we're on
to a new stage screw all that other
stuff throw the book away we're on to a
better thing no it's incorporating all
of that and keeping the riches
or if you like the realm of all these
previous shapes of spirits
in your back pocket ready to use when
you want to ready to recall to mind
so we've gotten about halfway through
the paragraph now
um
what's going on
in this immediacy of this new existence
Spirit has to start afresh
to bring itself to maturity as if for it
all that proceeded were lost and it had
learned nothing from The Experience what
it is the previous Spirits the previous
stages had gone through it might seem
that way to you is that really the case
Hegel is saying
no that isn't the case because what does
he say in the very next line
recollection the inwardizing of that
experience what the previous shapes of
Consciousness if we want to think about
this historically the previous
people
have gone through and passed on to to us
whether in writing you know for example
in the history of philosophy which Hegel
explores he has lectures on that right
where he's going to say here's what
Plato was was giving to us and coming
out of Plato's text here's what
Aristotle was doing now of course his
history you know when it comes to
Hellenistic philosophy maybe not quite
so good don't worry about that at this
point right
or it could be in action it could be in
Deeds it could be in
social organization it could be in
reflection on practical uh Affairs all
of those things
are the provinces of previous spirits
that the the spirit of the present can
recollect so recollection
is in part
what we've been doing in this
certainly
in the self-consciousness section
you know maybe the Master Slave
dialectic is mythical but stoicism
skepticism and the unhappy Consciousness
which are the larger section in that
that work
those aren't mythical those are supposed
to be
previous shapes of Consciousness that we
went through likewise all the things
that we found in the reason section all
the things that we found in the spirit
section all the things that we found in
the religion section are supposed to be
what human beings as a lowercase s
Spirits within the uppercase s Spirit of
that particular time culture
Dynamic what they experienced what they
went through what they attained but
didn't quite finish with right
so in this uh immediacy it started fresh
right recollection the inwardizing of
the experience has preserved it and is
the inner being and in fact the higher
form of the substance not a surprise
that Hagel thinks that where we are now
you know the end of the book the final
Viewpoint is a better one right and
here's where we start get getting into
the things that I've got sort of
diagrammed on the board
so he says although this Spirit starts
afresh and apparently from its own
resources to bring itself to maturity it
is nonetheless on a higher level that it
starts so we've got to sort of
bifurcated uh existence or Viewpoint we
could say the realm of spirits which is
formed in this way in the outer World
constitutes a succession
in time in which one Spirit relieved
another of its charge and each took over
the this is a beautiful phrase the
Empire of the world the ruling of the
world the determination of the world
from its predecessors so you know maybe
for a while we were into the Master
Slave dialectic and and you know could
happen again right barbarism occurs
and then from that we move into a new
Shape Of Consciousness in the
self-consciousness section stoicism
stoicism arises according to Hegel and
many other thinkers as well who by the
way are kind of getting this wrong it
arises when we realize a kind of
universal slavery or bondage and we've
lost the original you know Greek city
state uh everybody knows everybody sort
of context don't worry about whether
that's true or not for Hegel what he's
saying is once you've got stoicism on
the scene it has taken over from the
Master Slave dialectic right what was
important in that has been transported
into a new Shape Of Consciousness and
then skepticism will take over from
stoicism as stoicism fails as a new
Shape Of Consciousness or shape of
spirit and then skepticism isn't the
final word either because the unhappy
Consciousness the longest section in the
self-consciousness section will take
over again
right and then we'll move into an
entirely different section with reason
and then spirit and then religion and
then finally absolute knowing so each of
these stages that we have gone through
in this text
has been
taking us from one Shape Of
Consciousness which
didn't think of itself as finished
into another which is like you are
finished buddy let me do the the work
now and you just take it easy there
Grandpa old man right so um
what is the goal of this the goal is the
Revelation the orphan borrow the
Revelation to us of the depth of spirit
and this is the absolute notion the
absolute big if the absolute concept
which is what we get in absolute knowing
and so he goes on and he says this
Revelation is the raising up of its
depth right so we we had a revelation of
the depths of spirit we need to plumb
those depths and bring things out
or an extension or its extension the
negativity of this withdrawn eye and eye
that withdraws itself and negativity
which is notice the term we're coming
back to here the externalization uh is
its externalization or its substance and
then it says something else
this Revelation this wolfenbag this
showing us something
is also the Notions time
right so it is the concepts
time
now why is he talking about Revelation
here didn't we leave that behind with
religion the revealed religion uh
Christianity
well I mean one way you could think
about this is
you can't force revelation
and you know what do we typically
opposed to Revelation reason rationality
right and you can say well we can
develop everything that we need we don't
need a revelation from some sort of
divine and the Revelation here isn't
from a Divine who is separate and higher
than us it is a revelation to ourselves
of what Spirit can actually be in
absolute knowing so it's a revelation
it's a self-revelation
but it is nonetheless a revelation it
has to happen
when the time the zeit is actually ripe
when it's full right when it is been
brought to its Perfection or its
fulfillment
which can't happen in the previous
stages even though they wanted it to
happen in the previous stages it's got
to happen according to Hegel
here at the end
the end of History
so he goes on and he says
this Revelation is the notion's time in
that this externalization is in its own
self-externalized and just as it is in
its extension so it is equally in its
depth in the self in in its not just in
how it's extended you know numerically
but in we could say it's quality or it's
intensity it's complexity
here he says the goal Zeal is absolute
knowing
or spirit that knows itself as Spirit of
formulation that we've encountered
already in the previous paragraphs
spirit is getting to know what Spirit
truly is it already did that to some
extent but here it's finished it has
been brought to its fruition
and what does that mean
spirit that knows itself is Spirit or
absolute knowing has for its path
the recollection of the spirits
all the previous spirits
how
well he tells us the spirits as they are
in themselves
and as they accomplish the organization
of their Realm they're right they're
riches their place
this is going to lead us to two
complementary ways of looking at things
that we have already seen come up in the
previous paragraphs not least the
paragraph Just preceding this right
and this is where we're going to get to
the end
so he tells us their preservation
regarded from one side what side the
side of free existence
so Freedom existence design
is
um
appearing in the form of contingency
right contingency zoophilicite things
could be different than they are so you
know
um did the master and slave have to do
things the way that they did no did
stoicism have to emerge necessarily uh
you know it just showed up on the on the
scene you know as we know actually
epicureanism preceded it as did cynicism
but you know in hegel's schema we're not
going to worry about those so much at
least in the phenomenology
so it seems like history is a bunch of
contingencies this war is fought this
development takes place some new
doctrine is is worked out by this guy
over here a printing press is designed
and books start getting published no
longer copied up by monks or scribes but
you know in printing presses and you
know it's all just kind of random stuff
that happens
it's not completely of course as we know
history is not just like one damn thing
after another as some people like to say
it's not just a bunch of trivia either
understanding history again a bit of an
aside there's there's a lot of people
who call themselves history Buffs and
they don't know a damn thing about
history because what they lack is how
things are actually connected together
they're like yeah this thing happened
and that thing happened and this thing
happened and I've got them all memorized
up here
but that's just trivia
it's like memorizing baseball statistics
you gotta actually know how the game is
played you got to know what it all means
and what the individual Parts mean okay
digression over
so free existence appearing in the form
of contingency that is history but we
can look at it in another way
we can talk about it as the side of
their and Miller is interpolating here
philosophically but that's fine
comprehended
organization right now organize
organization
um Hegel actually uses the the Latin at
word there that we just translate as the
cognet
so we can look at things in two ways we
can look at the succession of uh Spirits
in time we can look at the organization
of them and we get two different things
we get history or we get the science of
knowing in the sphere of appearance
which is not exactly what Hagel says he
is science Vision shaft there
isons right so
um the science of if we want to be a
little bit more literal of
appearing knowledge of knowledge that
displays itself that that emerges
through appearing to us showing itself
to us yeah shine in there right so
you know we could say okay over here
we've got
um you know history over here we have
visenshoff science an understanding of
it and they're both complementary
viewpoints on this entire process
now there's actually an interesting
footnote here
um Miller is going to say science of
knowing in the sphere of appearance is
phenomenology the very phenomenology of
spirit
is it isn't it
that's kind of a bold interpretive move
here that I think we have to be a little
bit
leery of
now what's really important
we've got these two sides
they're United
together
you know bringing them together
they form building
you know or actually not build it but
stay in right the constitute
um they uh together are what he calls
comprehended history
so it's not like we had history and then
we have like history's explanation over
here this is all history
but it's conceived conceptual history
history in the concept the kind of
history that Hegel takes himself is
doing in his other works
and he tells us some stuff about this
it's an inwardizing
now inwardizing is a weird way to
translate
recollection it's a recollection and
Calvary shot is shadowstata right
um okay so that that's some you know
nice metaphorical language there of
absolute spirit and then he says
something I think even more important so
here's another Triad right what is this
the actuality the truth and the
certainty of his throne
Spirit throne knowing's throne
our throne as the person understanding
these things engaging in comprehended
history
now where have we seen these terms
before so truth and certainty there's
been this constant back and forth right
we start with certainty and then we
realize well we're not quite so certain
so we try to reach out for truth the
height we say what is the truth of this
thing that we take as being certain and
we gain the truth but we lose the
certainty in the process and then we're
like oh crap we need to get cert how do
we know that this truth is actually
truth or can we be certain of it and
then we move back to certainty and we
want to have things that are true and
certain we want truth and certainty
together but we don't want just a mere
idealism stuck in our little heads we
want actuality a term that we again have
seen so many times here in the
phenomenology playing such a massive
role Hagel is about getting to actuality
not just making Castles in the Sky or
nice conceptual schemas
he wants to cognize to conceptualize
to exist within to change
the world in which we are at the end of
this dialectical process so the
dialectical process it finishes itself
up through a new world a new existence a
new actuality that encompasses truth and
certainty
for us
and then this leads us
you know we have to have this actuality
truth uncertainty of his throne without
which he would be lifeless
and alone
and here we get the final line only from
The Chalice of this realm of spirits
Foams forth for him his own infinitude
this is the infinite
brought into
our reality
there for us
and so with this
we bring hegel's phenomenology of
spirits
our study of it our commentary on it to
what I hope for you seems like a
successful
close I won't say necessarily
termination because
as I pointed out you may want to go back
and re-read you may want to devote
additional study to this work but
as far as this work on our part of
trying to figure out what the hell is
Hegel actually saying
we are now
finished
and I hope that you have found these
commentaries useful for not only helping
you understand what Hagel himself is
saying in this quite difficult text
but that you've enjoyed this you've
found it
interesting you have
allowed it to permeate your own life and
thinking and made it part of who you are
and perhaps even then perplexed enough
to wonder whether Hegel actually got all
this stuff right or not so on that we
finish up and
happy hunting through hegel's
phenomenology on your part throughout
however long these commentaries last